so you're actively lobbying your
Congressman right now to support Israel
correct
we're on Capitol Hill where a PACs
annual conference is coming to a close a
pact of course is the powerful
pro-israel lobby group that works to
shape US policy in Israel's favor and to
make sure that the military aid keeps
flowing there and it all comes to a
close here where they bussed in
thousands of their supporters to do just
that is what's good for Israel
necessarily good for America
absolutely what about on specific
foreign policy issues where the
interests have not aligned that Iran
deal for example we have we have to
support the American president whether
it's right or wrong but AIPAC spent 30
million dollars
eat it right the pie is really coming
aster flew to Congress about the
president knowing to try to get the
Congress members against it how those
interests align they sometimes don't
they sure when international law says
that site settlements are violation do
you think it's right for members of
AIPAC to be lobbying their elected
officials in the United States for
something that is against America stated
position sometimes friends can have
differences of opinion and they're a
sovereign nation they make their own
decisions so obviously you're speaking
of like the two-state solution type of
thing the different obviously like the
Palestinians and the Israelis and Oliver
the current expansion of settlements are
by illegal Israeli settlements on
Palestine where illegal this really said
well that's what they are I'm going to
international law according to well I
would rather actually not comment on it
one thing I always do there I said if
you can live in any country an ability
to square what you want to live they all
tell me how to percent I want an
additional I like it here I'm prospering
well but they can't because they live
yeah we don't consider documentation
I've been there well doesn't mean
they're right do you think that it's
important to address this though when
you're talking about peace are you
talking about Israel and America's
interest we're where we have an American
is really an interesting gather for
peace we want these but we also believe
Israel is a sovereign nation and they
have a right to settle the pieces
themselves and I think this will be like
some other country coming and telling us
Americans how to solve our usage well we
should say that what Prime Minister
Netanyahu did last year